pauli le los angeles je veux que vous
ouvriez la portière et que vous mettiez
vos mains à l'extérieur du véhicule
maintenant
ton mis un genou à dépêcher soir c'est
ça pascal un nouveau s'appelle hollande
oui monsieur nick holland c'est moi tu
montes ou pas
j'aimerais que tu écoute attentivement
et bien ce qui se passe ici dans cette
voiture de police et il ya ce qui se
passe en dehors de cette voiture près
cette nuit soit tu va réconcilier tout
ça
soit pas ce boulot va te manger tout cru
parce que quoi que tu fasses et où que
tu ailles ça peut être des emmerdes en
perspective
tu peux me croire mais c'est la guerre
dans les rues si ce sera nous tous
contre lui
je suis et tu fais exactement comme moi
et toi genou immédiatement aux tirs
je sais pas si je suis fait pour ça
j'ai quelque chose qu'il faut que tu
creuses moche comment y a pas plus moche
ils ont des gosses
wave vous pouvez pas vous mettre en roue
libre comme ça enfin l'information pour
cette nuit
dis moi ouais
je suis pas engagée dans la police pour
saab
les gens dorment paisiblement dans leur
lit la nuit car des hommes coriace sont
prêts à commettre des violences en leur
nom
[Musique]
eh ben tu vois c'est incroyable comme tu
apprends vite
[Musique]